Nothing can keep me down.
I've been attacked
by terrorists, asteroids,
film critics, music critics,
restaurant critics,
divorce lawyers,
male-pattern baldness,
and none of it --
none of it stopped me
because I am still
Bruce Fuckin' Willis.
[ Cheers and applause ]
People ask me why
I did this roast.
Was it because one of
the last guys who did it
became president?
Hell no.
Why would I want to be president
when I can just keep being
Bruce Fuckin' Willis?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Huh?
Yeah?
I did this roast for one reason
and for one reason only --
to settle something
once and for all.
Now, please,
listen very carefully.
"Die Hard" is not
a Christmas movie!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a goddamn
Bruce Willis movie.
So, yippee ki-yay
to all of you motherfuckers.
Good night!
[ Cheers and applause ]